BEING COPY OF HER CHILDREN’S
BOOK "SUPER HEROS ARE
EVERYWHERE."
>> I’D HAVE TO CHECK ON THAT.
HERE’S A GOOD BOOK.
>> Martha: OKAY.
FORMER ACTING DEPUTY SECRETARY,
KEN CUCCINELLI IS HERE.
THEY SAID SHE CAN’T GO BECAUSE
OF COVID ISSUES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S ONE MORE
SMOKE SCREEN.
I THINK MAYBE IT WAS JUST HER
ANSWER OFF THE TOP OF HER HEAD.
THEY ARE TAKING POSITIVE TESTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
IDENTIFICATION AND PUTTING THEM
ON PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION, BY
WHICH I MEAN TRANSPORTATION
SHARED WITH AMERICAN CITIZENS,
TO SEND THEM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
PAYING FOR IT.
IF THERE’S COVID ISSUES THAT
THEY’RE AFFLICTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WITH OR IF THEY’RE NOT SO
BAD, WHY CAN’T SHE GO VISIT?
THIS IS JUST TANGLED IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
IT’S REALLY JUST A BAD EXCUSE.
LET’S JUST CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
OKAY?
IT’S A BAD EXCUSE.
DOESN’T FIT.
ESPECIALLY PART OF THE REASON AT
THE BORDER WE HAVE COVID ISSUES,
THEY’RE INVITING IN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY THAT ARE COMING UP IN
PETRI-LIKE CONDITIONS IN THE
BACK OF TRAILERS, THEY’RE
STAYING IN STASH HOUSES WITH
OTHER PEOPLE THAT THEY DON’T
KNOW.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, PRECAUTIONS ARE
NOT BEING TAKEN.
IT’S JUST RIDICULOUS ON TOP OF
RIDICULOUS.
UNLESS SHE’S JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT HER OWN SAFETY.
THEN IT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
>> Martha: SHE WAS VACCINATED.
WE SAW THAT.
SHE PUT IT OUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO SHE WAS VACCINATED.
SO YOU KNOW, IT RAISES SO MANY
QUESTIONS.
IT’S SAYING IF YOU ARE ACCEPTING
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY, RIGHT?
YOU WANT TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEM WHAT IS WHAT JEN PSAKI
IS SAYS, WE’RE MANAGING THIS
WELL, MOVING THEM TO FACILITIES,
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN SO
CAREFUL AND BY THE POLLS
EFFECTIVE IN DEALING WITH COVID.
SO WHY AREN’T THEY SAYING WE
HAVE A PROCESS, WE’RE
QUARANTINING PEOPLE FOR THIS
AMOUNT OF TIME BEFORE WE PUT
THEM ON THE BUSES.
IT SEEMS LIKE A REAL OVERSIGHT
AND A REAL CONTRADICTION TO
THEIR OTHER POLICIES WHERE THIS
VIRUS HAS BEEN CONCERNED.
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW THAT IT’S
AN OVERSIGHT.
THAT SUGGESTS THEY’RE NOT AWARE
OF IT AND SAID WHOOPS.
I THINK THEY DON’T CARE.
BECAUSE ANYTHING ALONG THE LINES
THAT YOU DESCRIBED, ALL OF WHICH
MAKES SENSE, SLOWS DOWN THE
IN-PROCESSING.
THEY SEEM DETERMINED TO
FACILITATE NOT TO SLOW DOWN, NOT
TO CHECK, NOT TO SEGREGATE BY
HEALTH PURPOSES ANY OF THESE
FOLKS.
>> Martha: IT’S AMUSING.
>> THEY --
>> Martha: I’M THINKING ABOUT
HOW THE CONTRAST BETWEEN WHAT
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT AND THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS WEARING
HIS MASK, HE’S BEEN VACCINATED
AND TELLING EVERYBODY THAT
FOURTH OF JULY PARTIES MIGHT NOT
HAPPEN BECAUSE NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
ARE MAKING SURE THAT THEY DON’T
GET KEVIN.
SO THERE’S SUCH A DICHOTOMY.
ON THE WAY OUT HERE BECAUSE I
HAVE TO GO AND I THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE, MR. CUCCINELLI.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF KAMALA
HARRIS’S BOOK IN ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES.
FOLDED UP ON A BLANKET.
WE HAVE THAT PICTURE.
THIS IS WHAT GREETS THE KIDS AS
THEY COME IN.
IT’S NICE THAT THEY’RE GETTING A
BOOK TO READ ON THE WAY IN.
IT’S THE BOOK WRITTEN BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
SO ANYWAY, TAKE AWAY FROM THAT
WHAT YOU WILL.
>> IT SURE LOOKS LIKE A REALLY
LOW LEVEL AND PETTY CONFLICT OF